[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
marsh is not swamp
marsh is a space of light
where grass grows in water
and water flows into the sky
[Music]
then within the marsh here and there
true swamp
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
a swamp knows all about death
and doesn't necessarily define it as
tragedy
certainly not a sin
i thought chase andrews would have more
common sense
best quarterback this town ever had
[Music]
boys
are these your footprints here yes sir
where's his footprints
yeah some kids just get crazy ideas in
their heads and drink
think they're invincible
chase andrews there's no kid
hey
look at this
he opened a great himself could have
been an accident all the same
time of death between midnight and 2 am
cause of death sudden impact from the
63-foot drop
since you found that blood and hair on
the support beam
i would deduce that was the cause of the
primary injury
layman's terms bang the back of his head
on the way down
to hit the back of his head on the beam
he would have needed to fall backwards
is that right i'd say yes
so he might have been pushed there's no
fingerprints on the railing the grades
nothing no fingerprints
not from chase either
no fingerprints no tracks
we do have those
red fibers found on the jacket
i just got the lab report back from
atlanta they did not come from any of
his other clothing
well it says
a
sweater scarf hell it could be anything
and we got to find it
beautiful wife good family i can't think
anyone who'd want to kill chase come on
you know what chase was tom cat and
rutting around like a pinned up bullet i
don't speak kill the dead frank i'm just
saying i can think of a few guys let's
do it mr milton oh sandy the usual
bronze wick stew how did you grasp
what do you make of the chase andrew's
case tom oh i'm retired that's none of
my business anymore fair enough could
have been that woman lives out in the
marsh crazy enough for the loony bin i
just bet she'd be up to something like
this well my brother's always told me
that marsh girls are missing lane you
know poor chase andrews had something
going on down in that marsh chase
andrews and the marsh girl now if that
ain't asking for trouble
what do you think really happened frank
you think that marsh girl could have
killed chase hell i don't know truth
will come out
wow
look at all these feathers and whatnot
she a scientist
or a witch
miss clark
sheriff's department chair
look
could get a warrant
plain view
drop up a call sheriff
but that door hadn't even locked
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
there she is
go straight go straight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know you yeah chase andrews
ms clark
i'm tom milton
i'm a lawyer may i come in
well thank you mr frasier
you probably know that you're being held
for the murder of chase andrews well i
i've taken the liberty of putting myself
forward to defend you
you